[Musique]
chaque jour nous sommes nous sommes
entassés comme des sardines dans deux
boîtes on arrive fatigué on arrive à
bien étudier
il faut qu'on nous ajoutons vraiment
davis
[Musique]
bien avant
à ces personnes c'est un peu difficile
parce qu'il ya des gens qui sortent dé
travailler et consorts mais la semaine
qu'il en trouvera un
[Musique]
tes objectifs également aujourd'hui
c'est de pouvoir toucher toutes les
classes sociales
on a commencé avec une classe moyenne
mais on voudrait garder le même standing
avec les différents modèles de véhicules
afin afin de pouvoir répondre aux
besoins de toute la population
[Musique]